a certified Avalanche dog like Cali can
do the work of about 30 rescuers in the
same amount of time their sense of smell
is ten times the greater than ours and
if someone's buried in the snow are not
even buried but just lost in the woods
the dog can smell their scent coming up
through the snowpack and tell me where
to start digging to find that person we
are the first responders and a lot of
times if things go well into our
training we can facilitate that rescue
without putting anybody else in harm's
way and be done quickly and efficiently
and I'll go home safely
Brooke we got to find somebody I know
you won't find somebody okay let's go my
name is hunter Mortensen I'm Avalanche
technician here at Breckenridge skiers
or with my ski patrol partner Italian
we've been working here for 8 years
together we're really fortunate here at
Breckenridge we have six avalanche
rescue dogs on staff today
Tally's here and with her co-workers and
Friends is Boudreaux the golden
retriever and a up another Mountain
purebred mutt the years of the big st.
Bernard and Swiss Mountain Dog with the
Beryl under their neck those dogs are
built for the mountains they're sturdy
they're Hardy they can do it but what
we're finding is they don't travel well
in the snow and they're not as fast
moving across the snow avalanche rescue
is all a matter of time so we're looking
these days for dogs that are a little
bit on the smaller side a little more
nimble in a little more quick
so the training we start them six to
nine months old and a lot of it is just
basic obedience and then we start
building from the obedience into actual
hide-and-go-seek type games and then we
build up from there into big snow caves
where we'll bury a person almost six
feet deep if we have enough snow and
then the dog will start searching having
to find where that fence coming up to
play the game and all they're really
looking for is that person who they
think has actually it's about two full
years of training to take your last
certification test for an avalanche
rescue dog and handler so I'm certified
to work with tally my whole last eight
years of my career have been spent with
her every day all day when we have to do
our thing we're really dependent on each
other and I couldn't do what I do
without her and so it's an amazing
partnership and I'm really honored and
proud to be a part of this program and
work with the dog like her from the very
first time I did a run I was hooked at
the competition and my family were about
competition
[Music]
when you get behind that horse and it
doesn't matter how many years you've
done it you're a little bit worried you
know certain things can happen on that
course to change your life forever
[Music]
the durian is basically down on 800-foot
track with a horse that's towing you
going over three jumps getting three
sets of rings the fastest time wins ooh
boom boom
sounds relatively easy but when you're
doing 40 miles an hour behind this 1500
pound animal it gets to be really
exciting
[Music]
skiers can crash horses can crash and
anything can happen a lot can go wrong
in 17 seconds
[Music]
I'm fourth generation on the ranch I was
on the horse for my first time at 24
hours old I came back to the hospital
and my dad was on the horse and so I got
thrown up on the horse with my dad and
then this keep on riding
you guys ready to run I just scheme
since I was two years old some racing
teaching skiing for 20 years
she joined is like no other rush you've
ever had it is an adrenaline junkie
sport
you really have to work together it's
teamwork but you both got to really know
what you're doing - just exceed your
ninth in the run order that what we need
to do this if we watch every runner
before us there are two different
cultures in this sport you've got a
bunch of rednecks or Hicks or Ranchers
and you got a bunch of hippie for this
event they get together and they all get
along melding them together is important
to become a pull on team all-out I'll
kick ass take names yep
[Music]
I've been skiing since I was four years
old my name is Claudia and I ski or
working I spend most part of a year
close to the mountain
when I spend time away from it I feel
nostalgic likely something is missing to
my soul to my life and in this moment I
take my ski and I walk
[Music]
Mount Etna is located on the east coast
of Sicily is known as the tallest and
active work on under you
the risk climbing Mount Etna are the
same of any other mountain
you have to be careful and respect
what's surrounding us
the view from the top is unique you can
see the landscape changing many times
from cream boots to desert volcanic area
all the lava flow and the cost black
powder is volcanic sand and its format
during the eruption
it's incredible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
by the Bonhams pop quiz who is this
[Music]
if you answered Olympic gold medalist
freestyle skier Jonny Moseley you are
correct it is talking Mosley hey I'm
Jonny Moseley here's another question
what exactly is Jonny Moseley doing
right now
it's strange it's as if johnny is figure
skating unskilled what you are
witnessing is a rare glimpse of a loss
athletic art that was once the pinnacle
of freestyle skiing it had judges it had
costumes
it has fans it had a name even I
[Music]
in the beginning Dunphy saw skiers
didn't just want to speed down they
wanted to ski fun and they invented a
new sport that would eventually make it
all the way to the Olympic Games ski
ballet was born
yeah it just looked like a bunch of
crazy stuff on skis this is three-time
world champion skier Bob Howard a legend
in ski ballet when the sport was in is
1982 a day what they didn't know then
you don't know now ski ballet is very
difficult I'd like to demonstrate my
knees are shot so I brought in Jonny
Moseley I'm Jonny Moseley they know ski
ballet was a form of freestyle skiing
and it had a couple different
corporations it had pole flips
[Music]
spins linking tricks we put it all
together with rock and roll music early
on we did to move so we're basically
flexed tricks where you go off your tips
and what it is is you flex your tip up
and you spin around
those are pretty difficult because
you're balancing and you can hurt
yourself real quickly you can dislocate
your knee and instant here's Johnny
doing a 720 which is two times around we
copied this from ice-skating and then
even goes to a higher level where he
goes to a 900 which means he spins
around two times lands backward the
Lakeland ski ballet were never brighter
than when there was a demonstration
sport in the Olympics in 1988 and 1992
but ski ballet was not long for this
world
the spotlight dimmed when the games
dropped it in 1994 and the whole sport
was fully dark not long after the DNA of
ski ballet is actually in everything
that freestyle is today all these spins
and moves to see him silk style in the
big air we did all that from the very
beginning that's why I teach my students
new ballet moves I'm going to do a film
a cross-legged pose
so the next time you're on a chairlift
and you spy Jonny Moseley down below
clad in a retro onesie and painting a
ski masterpiece on a canvas of virgin
snow take a moment to realize that your
glimpsing the flight of a Phoenix a
Phoenix called Steve LA
you
you